agriculture à présent cet après midi à
l'ancienne se tenait la soixante
douzième assemblée générale de la fdsea
les membres de la fédération
départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles sont revenus sur
leurs actions et leur travail mené au
quotidien l'occasion également
d'interpeller une nouvelle fois le
gouvernement sur la crise des
agriculteurs et leurs problématiques
williams elle pour ce reportage
c'est un profond désarroi qui
caractérise l'état d'esprit des
agriculteurs français aujourd'hui ce 19
mai la fdsea organisait sa 72e assemblée
générale permettant un état des lieux
des travaux du syndicat mais aussi de
mettre à jour les problématiques
rencontrées par les agriculteurs
il ya une absence de revenus les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui est souvent ces
agriculteurs sérail et qu'on stigmatise
de nantis et s'est régulièrement ne
vivent plus de leur métier
c'est à dire que on a une majorité de
nos exploitants en ile-de-france qui ne
gagnent pas leur vie depuis un an et
demi deux ans parce qu'en fait les cours
sont très bas et les charges très très
hot dans le viseur la sueur
administrations françaises et des
agriculteurs qui se sentent abandonnés
par leur ministère concernant les
retards de paiement mais l'assemblée
générale est aussi l'occasion de faire
le point sur les avancées réalisées en
matière d'environnement
il ya des changements sur la politique
des nitrates ya des changements sur la
boutique des produits phytosanitaires
avec un certain nombre de bonnes
pratiques que l'on a pu écrire pour
protéger les abeilles pour avancer sur
la communication est sûr essayer de
faire mieux comprendre notre métier
aujourd'hui à beaucoup d'interrogations
et on doit y répondre et on y répond au
menu également des problématiques plus
locales comme l'installation des gens du
voyage sur des parcelles agricoles dans
les yvelines
ici la fdsea interpelle directement la
préfecture ou encore l'installation d'un
supermarché hague a lui les difficultés
aujourd'hui bain
dans les yvelines problème de foncier
donc avec l'agrandissement de toutes les
les vies et les contraintes les
infrastructures urbaines etc après les
difficultés sur un marché mondial ne pas
avoir les mêmes normes de peut être un
moteur que le pays comme l'allemagne
l'espagne les gros problèmes qu'on
rencontre actuellement mais c'est lui
justement c'est la ligne mpn paris
normandie qui sont le projet continua à
se peaufiner et le gros souci est que
nous personnellement on n'en veut pas
parce qu' il n'est pas question d'avoir
de la nouvelle emprise sur notre
territoire
selon la fdsea le poids des normes
seraient une entrave à la compétitivité
de la france en matière d'agriculture
la crise agricole principal sujet de
cette journée risque de rester encore
longtemps sur le tapis et je vous disais
en titre les autolib s'implante de plus
en plus dans les yvelines après le
chesnay et vélizy en 2006 ans versailles
a accueilli ses premières véhicule du
syndicat autolib à la fin du mois
d'avril trois stations sont déjà
présentes dans la commune yvelinoise
d'autres communes de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc vont elles aussi
proposé des stations d'autopartage
électrique des précisions de mélanie
potier cette bande et véhicules à deux
pas de la mairie tout près de la gare
versailles rive gauche depuis la fin du
mois d'avril la commune possède 21
véhicules répartis sur trois stations ça
fonctionne très bien parce que le
démarrage en quinze jours trois semaines
on a déjà plus de 160 abonnés annuels
c'est un très très bon complément de
mobilité avec les bus avec la bicyclette
avec la marche à pied pour les
versaillais qui était très demandeur de
ce mode de déplacement entre paris et
versailles et d'autres villes de la
région parisienne dans le courant de
l'année viendront s'ajouter celles de
versailles chantiers et satori quatre
autres stations sont à l'étude
elle devrait voir le jour courant 2010
est à bois d'arcy l'installation est
encore au stade de projet de station
devrait voir le jour à la zone
d'activités de la croix bonnet et près
de l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
grandes artères de la commune
c'est un vrai complément de transport
pour les artisiens mais aussi
du point de vue développement durable
puisque les stations seront équipées de
bornes de rechargement et donc du coup
les arts six ans pour des véhicules
électriques pourront prendre un
abonnement talus et recharger leurs
véhicules sur ces bornes de versailles
grand parc finance les installations à
hauteur de 50% avec le chesnay et vélizy
qui propose déjà ce service cette
agglomération possède pour le moment
très station et nous avons parlé habitat
participatif ce soir avec nos emplettes
au romulus akinocho membres du collectif
tintamarre bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors revenons
sur l'habitat participatif il est apparu
en france dans les années 1970 de paris
à toulouse on recense aujourd'hui en
france environ 400 groupes d'habitat
participatif et nous en dire un peu plus
donc samedi 21 mai à l'occasion des
journées européennes de l'habitat
participatif
vous organisez donc avec tout le
collectif à la verrière une journée
portes ouvertes donc de 10h30 à 17h30
pour faire découvrir le projet de la
mare c'est un projet qui est né en 2014
pour construire un habitat participatif
alors tout d'abord pour être un habitat
participatif c'est surtout être acteur
de son habitat donc en général lorsqu'on
veut accéder à un logement va visiter on
regarde ça nous convient et à ce moment
là on achète
là on est en amont du projet c'est à
dire qu'on a la possibilité de voir tous
les détails participé à la construction
et comment être comment définir son chez
soi si on veut avoir une chambre plus
grande
un simple petit enfin selon seulement
chaque personne seulement s'ils sont
mauvais alors le projet de la mare c'est
ainsi qu'il s'appelle c'est à la
verrière comment les certitudes
combien de personnes va-t-il hébergés
oui bien sûr en fait le projet qui
s'articule
l'objectif c'est d'avoir quatorze
familles quatorze foyers donc
actuellement nous sommes cette famille
donc justement le les portes ouvertes
c'est la possibilité de présenter le
projet à de nouvelles familles qui
seraient éventuellement intéressés à
découvrir et à faire un achat dans le
participatif tout simplement et donc le
projet il s'est donc tout l'association
et a été chapeautée par quoi de conseils
qui nous a accompagnés tout au long
pardon de moi quand je suis arrivé je ne
connaissais absolument rien à l'habitat
participatif donc j'ai tout découvert et
tout appris avec eux au fur et à mesure
donc voilà alors c'est un projet qui est
né aussi avec la mairie si vous
accompagne dessus ça s'articule comment
par rapport à ça c'est la mairie qui
donne le terrain et après c'est
exactement pas de construction
exactement donc l'idée c'est la mairie
qui qui lui a proposé les initiateurs du
projet qui propose là un terrain
magnifique qui s'est juste en face d'un
parc qui a gardé l'aspect sauvage
ensuite nous enfin le choix
l'association avait le choix de faire
appel à un bailleur social pour avoir
l'air un peu plus solides financièrement
sur la finalité du projet et donc donc
normalement donc fin de fin de cette
année il y avoir une promesse de vente
entre la mairie et les copies moqué le
bailleur social et ensuite à ce moment
là il y aura le lancement le permis de
construction et l'objectif justement
c'est d'avoir les clips pour début 2010
8 s'ils ont raison voilà vous choisissez
avec qui vous voulez vivre ensemble le
terrain l'architecte également voilà
tout à fait donc on est il ya eu on a
rencontré plusieurs engins tchité
architecte ou six architectes
il ya eu un concours et donc on le gagne
en est le projet que vous avez pu voir
et donc l'idée effectivement c'est
d'avoir un chacun son chez soi dans
l'habitat participatif
voilà c'est pas une communauté mais on
partage des lieux par exemple on va
avoir une salle commune l'on peut
partager une buanderie
mais voilà c'est il ya cet aspect
collectif mais il ya aussi chacun son
chez soi
voilà vous allez voilà prendre aussi
voilà un appartement dans cet habitat
participatif qu'est ce qui vous a attiré
dans cette aventure
en fait tout simplement moi je ne
connaissais pas du tout c'est ma
compagne en fait qui m'a amené dans une
présentation de réunions donc moi j'ai
écouté dans un premier temps et fur et à
mesure l'idée m'a plu parce que le
concept c'est quand même d'être on
repart serre l'une être citoyen du monde
c'est à dire qu'on part vers un habitat
plus écologique
donc c'est là on fait attention plus
économique aussi puisque l'idée aussi
c'est au niveau de l'énergie la volonté
c'est d'avoir une facture noir au niveau
de l'énergie en même temps quand on voit
le actuellement ce qui se passe dans le
monde
c'est c'est pas plus mal il ya un aspect
aussi solidarité intergénérationnelle
parce que vous êtes assez jeune pour
fait partie ce problème il ya des
personnes âgées également tout à fait
donc bien être des personnes retraitées
donc c'est reis et multi génère
intergénérationnel effectivement est
aussi multi social c'est le but parce
que on va s'enrichir les expériences des
uns et des autres par exemple je suis un
jeune père et moi dans l'idée c'est
effectivement il ya des partis qui sont
un peu plus âgés
j'aimerais elle fait j'ai pas mes
grands-parents avec moi j'aimerais
qu'ils puissent avoir l'expérience de
personnes plus âgées
non non non le quotidien alors donc il
ya de la mixité sociale ceci écologique
moi aussi c'est un avantage économique
auquel certains effectivement parce
qu'effectivement on part dans l'idée de
de partager les fonds donc on part sur
effectivement certains lieux qui sont
partagés donc ok là chacun va participer
financièrement donc ça permet donc le
l'habitat participatif ça peut être
effectivement la salle commune pour les
fêtes donc après c'est juste au niveau
de l'association un travail à faire
entre nous pour émettre des règles un
règlement intérieur une charte que que
tout le monde devait adhérer et afin de
vivre dans une convivialité
comment les familles sont choisis est ce
qu'il ya un dossier à déposer est-ce
qu'il faut respecter je sais pas
peut-être certains critères dont le new
le principalement le critère principal
s'évade opté la vision la vision qui
représente l'habitat participatif donc
c'est la possible et découvrir ses
voisins en fait c'est vrai que souvent
quand on arrive on connait passé en
voisin on arrive dans un appartement
l'idée là effectivement c'est d'avoir le
connaît de ses voisins déjà d'échanger
avec eux de se mettre d'accord sur la
manière dont on veut vivre ensemble
c'est un vivre autrement vivre ensemble
et autres et moi alors donc les
prochaines étapes du poulet donc là
samedi
samedi 21 mai donc les familles qui sont
intéressées peuvent venir
plus d'informations et après dumont
qu'il ya toutes les familles donc c'est
une dizaine dizaines de familles à tort
soigner sa torche famille voilà donc ces
c'est une fois qu'on a les quatorze
familles c'est en fait nous ont préféré
idéalement parce que on arrive à une un
moment charnière du projet auquel
effectivement vous avez vu la
présentation du projet maman choisir
comment on va être son appartement
c'est idéal pour les personnes d'arriver
à ce moment là pour pouvoir avoir aussi
leur avis sur le projet définitif et ça
se passe bien 2018 la construction
commencera là parfait et bien si vous
êtes 18 on comptait 18 on rentrait donc
ça va c'est assez rapide
en tout cas merci beaucoup d'être venu
soit pas tous les deux nous sommes avoir
parlé alors je le rappelle donc samedi
21 mai à l'occasion des journées
européennes de l'habitat participatif
vous organisez la verrière une journée
porte ouverte de 10h30 à 17h30 si vous
voulez plus d'information n'hésitez pas
allez sur le site internet www.steria.fr
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
merci à vous faut et on prend à présent
la direction du zoo de thoiry nous avons
parlé nouveau-né le printemps rime avec
naissance pour le parc
cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pour observer des
bébés aux wallabies des ouistitis les
oryx d'arabie des lémuriens ou encore à
des zèbres
michael almy d'euros a eu la chance
d'aller saluer ces nouveaux venus
regarder la famille touahri s'agrandit
le parc zoologique yvelinois qui recense
plus de 800 animaux et 120 espèces
enregistré 37 naissances en 2016 dont
une dizaine depuis le début du mois de
mai on essaie aussi de faire en sorte
que les naissances arrive à un moment où
c'est aussi le plus facile pour la
survie du petit c'est à dire qu'un petit
petites antilopes qui va naître en plein
hiver quand il fait moins dix ses
chances de survie sont un petit peu plus
faible que si l'aînée maintenant et que
ben il a tout l'été pour devenir un peu
plus fort et donc à bord aborder l'hiver
peut plus facilement évidemment ça
coïncide avec la période où le public
est là on va pas s'en plaindre
c'est forcément plus intéressant pour un
visiteur de voir de voir des animaux des
bébés
cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pourront observer des
bébé wallaby des ouistitis des zèbres
des bisous
cordes et oryx d'arabie cacher le plus
souvent dans les pattes de leur mère ces
naissances sont toujours bien accueillis
par les 60 employés du parc c'est pas
forcément un critère de que l'animal est
bien parce que les animaux c'est ça fait
partie de leur vie de se reproduire
donc voilà les autres animaux vous
mettez à mal une semaine globalement
souvent ça va se reproduire mais
évidemment quelle que soit la naissance
on est content donc là quand on a des
petits des petits du goût des petits
chevaux des petits trucs comme ça c'est
oui forcément on est content de
nouvelles naissances devraient avoir
lieu dans les prochaines semaines chez
les zèbres les antilopes et légumes où
chaque année le parc accueille entre 70
et 80 nouveaux pensionnaires du sport à
présent cinquante sportifs de haut
niveau étaient dans les yvelines ce
mardi les athlètes ont participé à la
24e édition du tibre est qu au golf de
la queue-lez-yvelines alors comme tous
les ans les joueurs se sont affrontés
dans une partie de golf avant de passer
quelques minutes avec des enfants venus
de trappes et de versailles dans la
soirée une vente aux enchères était
organisée au profit de sos gaz l on
écoute l'organisatrice véronique chaplin
elle était tonique rodez mika elle me
trouve
c'est vraiment des choses collector et
l'ensemble de l'argent va permettre de
financer 200 trains en île de france est
au sénégal
laurent blanc nous a porté le maillot de
verra-t-il le maillot de l'équipe du psg
signé de tous la tan et c'est le ballon
nous avons la raquette de yannick noah à
la raquette les règles quatre raquettes
des quatre finalistes de coupe davis
nous avons la vaysse de philippe
candeloro nous avons pas d des traits
des choses très prestigieuse et nous
recevons à présent sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros pour sa chronique sport du jeudi
pour soir mickaël un sort florane alors
je tenais réagir par rapport au tiebreak
leurs pilotes passé j'ai tenté de vous
acheter le maillot du psg signé par tous
les joueurs du psg mais malheureusement
c'était un petit peu de budget pour moi
est ce que me pardonner je vous parle
d'elle michael c'était calme et gentil
et leurs pensées mon revenu à notre
chronique alors aujourd'hui vous allez
nous présenter les rendez vous à ne pas
manquer ce week end alors je ne peux
rien vous cacher il y aura énormément de
rendez vous importants ce week-end dans
les yvelines pour le pas boire la tasse
ou toutes ces informations je vous
conseille de retenir votre souffle
on commence par de l'apnée a encore
risque de tomber à la piscine municipale
de saint cyr l'école ce dimanche 22 mai
andy cabreira avis à 1 ap les mises
en apnée liste de 45 ans d'origine
cubaine va tenter de parcourir la plus
grande distance possible en apnée
pendant six heures pour cela elle
sportive devrait effacer le record de
pascal maes et le français effectués 9,3
km le 7 février dernier pour le battre
andy s'entraîne au minimum deux fois par
semaine depuis trois mois à la force et
à l'intense les plus durs la plus
difficile c'est la gestion de l'effort
voilà pourquoi
l'alliance entre les six heures j'ai eu
beaucoup de calme malgré le fait qu'ils
aient je m'hydrate tous les 30 minutes
je m'arrête pour une minute et ses
déboires mais là tu es avec des roses ou
collègues dé l'eau et des sels minéraux
pourquoi s'est-il lancé ce défi fou un
miel alors c'est un record pour la bonne
cause florane chaque longueur effectué
par andy permettra de récolter 1 euro
pour financer un exosquelette pour aider
luna une enfant de 10 ans victime d'une
infirmité motrice cérébrale
la combinaison pourrait lui permet de se
déplacer en écoute et en combinaisons
que toutes ces minorités sociales
cette combinaison permet aux enfants
handicapés d améliorer leur motricité
donc et le crochet luna c'est mon élève
c'est une copine l'égard des magnifiques
donc judicieux entre les cordes et
pascal maes et mais pas les mots pour
n'importe quoi c'est qu'on cause c'est
les champions de gap et comédie en
choeur antique est une belle cause
devant c'est qu'il peut réussir ce défi
média j'en suis persuadé florane pendant
ses séances d'entraînement andy a
réalisé la même distance que le
précédent record en seulement trois
heures et 13 minutes autant dire qu'il a
toutes les chances pour battre ce record
fraude
il sera d'ailleurs à l'invité du sud du
cette fille de sport que vous présentez
à lundi prochain à 10h30 en exclusivité
on continue maintenant par de cyclisme
sur piste les amateurs de vélo de vrai
sprinter ce week-end pour aller au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le temple du cyclisme français sur une
nouvelle fois le théâtre d'une
compétition de haut niveau ce week-end
la coupe de france fenioux est
programmée de ce vendredi 20 mai à ce
beau samedi 21 mai au programme une
cinquantaine de courses
les amateurs pourront voir de la vitesse
dames et hommes de la poursuite des
courses aux points du scratch des
époques d'omnium au total 18 nations
sont représentées plus de 100
participants vont s'affronter parmi les
têtes d'affiché on retrouvera la
française lorie berton vice-champion du
monde 2016
l'anglais à jason kenny triple champion
olympique m'est égal mais aussi grégory
baugé neuf fois champion du monde un
beau plateau on écoute le pistard de
l'équipe de france françois pervis est
un beau plateau
bon bah nous il ya toute l'équipe de
france déjà et puis ensuite les
étrangers
des polonais qui ont marché très fort
tous tout cet hiver
et puis aussi sur le champion du monde
et champion olympique au dessus d'un
homme qu'elle ni l'anglais donc ça va
être intéressant de voir lui aussi ou
est ce qu'il en est oui c'est un petit
test mais on va pas en tirer de grandes
de grandes conclusions c'est juste pour
voir où est ce qu'on en est actuellement
et pour pour gérer au mieux la suite du
programme d'entraînement si vous voulez
réserver vos places c'est 10 euros à la
journée 15 euros pour les deux jours et
gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans il
reste quelques places en tribune florane
si l'envié vous prend d'aller voir du
cyclisme sur piste il reste quelques
places j'ai pas très long mais je vais
quand même à me renseigner ciel on
continue cette chronique par du football
et plus précisément par le championnat
de division d'honneur versailles ne
devra pas se manquer ce week-end les
versaillais deuxième du classement de dh
reçoivent les murs au troisième du
classement ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade de mont boron
le match est capital dans la course à la
montée versailles ne compte que trois
petits points de retard sur le premier
créteil lusitanos après son incroyable
série de six victoires consécutives
je vous rappelle que seul le premier du
classement montera en cfa la saison
prochaine et ce n'est pas encore fini on
termine par du basket là aussi le match
sera capital dans la course à la montée
si on ne saura plus où donner de la tête
1 dans les yvelines ce week end le
chesnay-versailles joue ce ce match si
important le match des play off de
nationale 3 pour savoir si oui ou non
l'équipe va monter en nationale 2 pas
l'année prochaine
dernier match ce dimanche à 15h30 les
yvelinoises reçoivent escaudain au
gymnase bel air l'équipe qui les avait
battus à 85 à 59 au match aller en cas
de victoire le ch est née retrouverez la
nationale 2 1 un an après l'avoir
quittée ce seront belles histoires tout
de l'histoire forum un happy end comme
on aime à vélo
michael merci à vous on se retrouver la
semaine prochaine parce qu'une prochaine
je bloque pour aujourd'hui comme
d'habitude très bien moins resté avec
moi je vous emmène à cannes tout de
suite troisième épisode de notre série
consacrée aux yvelinois présent au
festival direction la croisette et ses
coulisses aujourd'hui nous avons suivi
le directeur du cinéma des longs cours
un ancien étudiant de 3e de trappes et
nous avons rencontré également franck
provost le coiffeur des stars il a
débuté sa carrière dans notre
département
cannes 78 est signée alexis garneau
grigori canale et nicolas quirion vie de
se regarder
bienvenue à cannes on vous emmène dans
les coulisses du festival à strass
paillettes soirée à cannes de nombreux
professionnels viennent surtout faire du
business et des rencontres c'est le cas
de l'ubs beau quand le directeur du ciné
c est à elancourt le marché du film de
cannes est l'un des événements les plus
importants de l'industrie
cinématographique avec plus de dix mille
professionnels ici des producteurs des
distributeurs des vendeurs et des
programmateurs de festivals et que tes
films on trouve de tout à cannes le
meilleur comme le pire du blue
classiques aux plus surprenant le marché
du film c'est vraiment pour le
distributeur en fait les producteurs les
distributeurs qui vendent les films à
l'international et c'était vrai ça mais
il projette aussi des films
donc on va accéder fois de temps en
temps on peut réussir à choper si je
puis dire une invitation pour aller voir
un film ou deux mais c'est quand même
assez rare ont marché du film ya tout il
ya un peu tout et n'importe quoi enfin
ça c'est normal il ya tous les gens du
corps
la série z la série b et ses draps par
contre dans les sélections officielles
on va dire que ce soit quinzaine acide
enfin etc je vais pas toutes les citer
il ya quand même plutôt du bon voire du
très très bon on voit le un maximum de
films c'est vachement important pour
nous parce qu'on a
exploitant parce qu'on a assez peu le
temps de voir les films en amont dans
l'année parce qu on est tout le temps en
train de courir après la mécanique si je
puis dire
les projections de presse appareils en a
quelques unes on arrive à y aller mais
pas toujours ça ne bloque une demi
journée voire une journée
on n'a pas toujours le temps donc cannes
c'est vraiment loverdos si je puis dire
de deux films on les enchaîne on les
voit et on l'est on prend des notes
et ensuite quand on les a aimés on les
programme et on les défend c'est ça qui
est important
cannes c'est également une chance pour
les plus jeunes de se faire un nom dans
le métier ou leurs ouailles est un
ancien élève des trois yes l'institut
international de l'image et du son de
trappes il n'a que 21 ans et déjà de
nombreux projets en tête cette année il
est venu à cannes pour travailler aux
côtés d'une attachée de presse
mais légalement emmené avec lui son
dernier court-métrage triangle une
histoire d'amour pourquoi ce film
ça va partir d'un constat très simple
c'est mon film de fin d'études donc il
fallait que je livre 1
et un film à telle date je savais qu'on
allait tourner c'est en troisième année
notre film de fin d'études et j'ai
cherché des idées et tout est en fait
finalement je me suis monsieur rabattu
abattu c'est pas le bon mot mais je me
suis fait parler d expérience
personnelle en fait et à partir de là ce
qui était rigolo c'était de prendre
quelque chose que j'avais plus ou moins
vécu et faire joujou avec et puis d'en
faire un film et puis changer tous les
éléments du coup de départ mais voilà
quelques bars avaient peut-être aussi
envie de parler de moi et c'est
peut-être le plus simple si parler de ce
qu'on connaît pour s'amuser avec
moi depuis depuis tout petit je regarde
le festival avec avec mes parents à la
télé c'était un peu un rêve de gosse et
et c'est vrai que à la télé à tout côté
paillettes et à tous côtés comme ça et
en fait on se rend compte que quand on
est là les gens ne font que parler de
cinéma et c'est un côté beaucoup plus je
sais pas comment dire peut-être un peu
familial mais il ya un vrai côté on est
tous ensemble je sais pas combien on est
pour le festival mais c'est énorme on
est tous avec vous toute accréditation
on sait tous on se reconnaît dans la rue
on sait qu'on fait partie du festival
est en fait je trouve qu'on moi j'avais
fait des belles rencontres et on discute
avec plein de gens et en fait on ne
parle que de signer comme on dit est ce
que tu as vu tel film at-elle sélection
à celui-là il est super as tu l'as vu un
machin on discute en fait on sait
chanter place aussi pour essayer d'aller
au célèbre fin à la montée des marches
chose comme ça c'est de la bidouille et
c'est vraiment dix jours dans une
dulcinée vous pourrait se passer un truc
à paris qu on ne serait même pas c'est
ça c'est ça la magie et on se quitte
avec l'autre star du jour le coiffeur
franck provost c'est dans les yvelines à
saint germes en les kilos vers son
premier salon en 1975 et chaque année à
cannes avec ses équipes de coiffeur et
de maquilleurs et le sublime les stars
qui montent les marches pour un résultat
souvent en plein de magie et de glamour
un réel plaisir de devenir mais
effectivement on est là déjà pour
travailler et c'est pas vraiment on
travaille beaucoup et quand je savais
les coiffeurs on va coiffer d'une de on
est basé nouveau martinez mais on va on
se déplace dans tous les hôtels et ça
veut dire que des coiffeurs sans arrêt
ils feront la navette sur la croisette
avec leurs valises et tout et je peux
vous garantir que des valises ça pèse
parce que on
transportent les lacs les produits les
les épingles et où donc quand ils ont
fait ça ça arrive qu'on commence des
journées à 8 heures le matin pour des
photos et souvent à 23 heures ça se
termine donc c'est un vrai vrai de
challans mais en même temps il ya une
espèce de de dynamisme de 2 for i de la
part de tout le monde donc finalement on
oublie la fatigue quoi parce que ici à
il se passe quelque chose c'est magique
quoi ya pas de se trouve pas d'autres
mots que pour qualifier les cannes
cannes c'est magique qu'elle soit 118
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui et n'oubliez
pas comme le dit jean luc godard la
télévision fabrique de l'oublier le
cinéma fabrique des souvenirs
et c'est à présent la fin de ce journal
merci de nous avoir suivis demain
nouvelle édition du journal de fin de
semaine avec l essentiel de l'actu
présenté par wilfrid richy vos idées
sorties et loisirs ce sera avec lui quel
ennemi d'euros dans le site suite du
week-end quant à moi je vous retrouve
lundi pour le journal je vous souhaite
donc une bonne soirée et un excellent
week-end